par michel leblanc le pdg de la chambre
de commerce du montréal métropolitain
reçoit michel leblanc bonsoir le crabe
ou 1,10 dans ce point de presse puis
vous y étiez également ce matin disait
qu'il faut éviter la dévitalisation du
centre ville
est-ce qu'on en est là en ce moment il
ya un risque est un risque réel
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'actions qui
ont été annoncés aujourd'hui une partie
de celle vise à ramener les montréalais
vers leur centre ville durant l'été une
autre visée à attirer des touristes du
québec et l'extérieur du québec
tout ça est important le risque il est
surtout présentement au niveau des
travailleurs évidemment le risque est
réel sur les touristes étrangers qu'ils
ne viennent pas mais mais du point de
vue des travailleurs un centre vivre sa
vie de cette masse de gens qui a tous
les jours vient au centre-ville y
travaille consomme dans sa base
commerciale va rester le soir va aller
dans les lieux de diffusion culturelle
c'est ça qui sait ce qui se passe un
mois dans un centre ville et au moment
où on se parle tous centre-ville évident
les grandes tours sont vides et
l'inquiétude qu'on a c'est que les gens
sont craintifs et si demain matin la
santé publique autorisé les retours des
employés c'est pas clair que les
employés reviendrait à la semaine
prochaine alors qu'est ce qui manque
parce que là on est toujours dans le
télé travail obligatoire en ce moment
beaucoup d'entreprises disent on va
revenir en septembre
on va attendre pour être bien bien bien
certains qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire
pour que tout le monde puisse revenir
dans un contexte très sécuritaire
écoutez c'est exactement ce qu'on va
enclencher maintenant le gouvernement du
québec monsieur monsieur fête des
baigneurs à nous octroyer 8.5 millions
de dollars pour travailler avec les
décideurs du secteur privé on va
travailler sur plusieurs fronts le
premier front c'est évidemment comment
voir rassurer dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois les
travailleurs mais c'est pas seulement
par la communication mais aussi par
l'aménagement des locaux faisant en
sorte que les entreprises prennent des
décisions qui vont amener les employés à
être à l'aise de revenir au début c'est
simplement de les rassurer
ensuite il va falloir aussi rang soit
agréable les initiatives qu'on a lancé
on appelle on appelle ça j'aime
voyez au centre ville et le défi qu'on
se lance tout c'est dans un an
à travers ces décisions d'entreprise les
employés vont dire j'aime ça travaille
au centre ville
on a aussi évoqué beaucoup ça a retenu
l'attention
le fait que des espaces de travail
excédentaire pas juste parce que des
locaux sont paul oui et parce qu'à
l'intérieur des bail à long terme qui
ont été signés les entreprises ont
maintenant possiblement des surcapacités
parce qu'ils vont avoir des modèles
hybrides de travail est-ce qu'on va
vouloir se faire en sorte que ces deux
mises étages ne restent pas vides et
donc on va créer une plateforme qui ont
eu une vie de l'espace à bureaux sait
déjà qu'ils ont évoqués comme ça est ce
que c'est la bonne image faudra voir
parce que l'idée c'est quand même de
permettre à des entreprises qui ne sont
pas au centre-ville on veut penser à des
entreprises en régions qui sont
aujourd'hui peut-être que je devrais
avoir un pied à terre à montréal et je
ne veux pas m'engager à long terme où je
veux voir comment ça va se passer
alors ça va être comme en facilite tous
ces essais vers le centre-ville
je rajouterais on va essayer de lier des
entreprises avec des partenaires pour ça
fasse du sens mais est ce que est ce que
c'est pas trop rapide de parler de ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y est né spécu
dibella on va on va recommander le port
du masque en tout temps dans les milieux
de travail et on parle des variantes
puis madame drouin de la santé publique
dit attention il ya quand même une
troisième vague qui s'en vient est ce
que c'est le temps de parler du retour
au bureau il faut prendre les décisions
maintenant au niveau de la préparation
on le sait un rouleau compresseur qui
s'appelle la vaccination variant ou pas
troisième vague dans quelques semaines
ou pas la promesse des gouvernements
c'est que tous les canadiens vont être
vaccinés au moins avec une première dose
rapidement le premier ministre le goût a
dit si la saint jean donc ça s'en vient
que ça s'en vient rapidement la
possibilité de venir la santé publique
vols autorisés
il faut commencer maintenant à planifier
comment va travailler il va falloir
travailler ensemble devrait-on être
vaccinés pour revenir dans les bureaux
c'est une excellente question je pense
qu'on a un grand débat moi je peux vous
dire que tous les leaders d'affaires à
qui j'ai parlé du moins le message est
clair à mes employés j'encourage mes
employés à se faire vacciner
je n'ai pas entendu parlé jusqu'ici de
la décision de dire ce serait une
exigence pour venir mais c'est clair
qu'il ya un message extrêmement puissant
va vouloir les employés
sentant en sécurité et ça va dépendre du
geste que les autres posent autour de
nous un mot michel leblanc sur la grève
possible en fin de semaine ou dans les
prochains jours au port de montréal
la trêve entre le syndicat des
débardeurs et les employeurs arrive à
échéance dimanche qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la part du gouvernement
fédéral qui qui qui gère le port de
montréal écoutez c'est extrêmement
préoccupant et on se le dit le tout le
monde les yeux rivés sur cette salle de
discussion où ça a lieu vous le dites
c'est l'échéancier c'est dimanche
moi je ne peux pas présumer qu'il ne
s'entendront pas je pense que toutes les
parties sont conscientes de l'impact
économique qui serait dévastateur mais
je vous dis le gouvernement fédéral est
au courant et vous verrez fédéral nous
fait la promesse qu'il va agir pour
qu'il n'y ait pas d'arrêt très mal et si
un arrêt de travail c'est qu'est ce qui
se passe là il ya plus de conteneurs qui
rentre au port écoutez l'été dernier
deux jours de travail c'est 80 milles
containers qui n'ont pas bougé ces trois
mois de retard qui a fallu combler par
la suite c'est 600 millions de pertes de
ventes pour les grossistes de montréal
qui dépend des de ces arrivages 12 jours
c'est extrêmement grave et on est dans
cette période d'amos de relance si
dévastateur si on arrête travail je vous
dis la pression elle est énorme et les
regards sont sur la négociation jusqu'à
vendredi et jusqu'à dimanche et sur le
gréement fédéral oki dimanche en fin de
journée
merci michel leblanc merci à vous pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
m